-Performing his number-one song
"She Had Me at Heads Carolina"
from his album "Stereotype,"
give it up for Cole Swindell!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ I was out with the boys
catchin' up in a neon light ♪
♪♪
♪ Didn't know till we walked in
it was karaoke night ♪
♪♪
♪ She was in a circle of girls
chasin' a shot with a lime ♪
♪ She was laughin', they were
darin' her to get on the mike ♪
♪ One of 'em walked up
and turned in her name ♪
♪ Next thing I knew, man,
she was up on the stage ♪
♪ Singin' "Heads Carolina,
Tails California" ♪
♪ Maybe she'd fall for a boy
from South Georgia ♪
♪ She's got the bar in the palm
of her hand ♪
♪ She's a '90s country fan
like I am ♪
♪ Hey, I got a Chevy ♪
♪ She can flip a quarter ♪
♪ I'd drive her anywhere
from here to California ♪
♪ When this song is over,
I gotta find her ♪
♪ 'Cause she had me
at "Heads Carolina" ♪
♪♪
♪ She knew every word by heart,
didn't need no screen ♪
♪ No ♪
♪ I was raisin' my glass up for
her, I saw her smilin' at me ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ She had me down in the front
by the end of verse two ♪
♪ Like there wasn't no one else
in the room ♪
♪ We were singin' "Heads
Carolina, Tails California" ♪
♪ Maybe she'd fall for a boy
from South Georgia ♪
♪ She's got the bar in the palm
of her hand ♪
♪ She's a '90s country fan
like I am ♪
♪ Hey, I got a Chevy ♪
♪ She can flip a quarter ♪
♪ I'd drive her anywhere
from here to California ♪
♪ When this song is over,
I gotta find her ♪
♪ 'Cause she had me
at "Heads Carolina" ♪
♪♪
♪ Well, I bought her a round
and we talked ♪
♪ Till the lights came on ♪
♪♪
♪ I still see that girl every
time I hear that song ♪
♪ "Heads Carolina,
Tails California" ♪
♪ Maybe she'd fall for a boy
from South Georgia ♪
♪ She's got the bar in the palm
of her hand ♪
♪ She's a Jimmy Fallon fan
like I am ♪
♪ Hey, I got a Chevy ♪
♪ She can flip a quarter ♪
♪ I'd drive her anywhere
from here to California ♪
♪ When this song is over,
I gotta find her ♪
♪ 'Cause she had me
at "Heads Carolina" ♪
♪ Yes, she did ♪
♪ She had me at
"Heads Carolina" ♪
♪♪
"Tonight Show," Jimmy Fallon,
thank y'all so much
for having us.
[ Cheers and applause ]